most on-screen versions of Superman and
Batman have looked a lot like they do in
the original DC Comics but not all
superheroes are created equal some of
the most iconic superheroes have
received major makeovers when they
jumped off the printed page here's how
DC superheroes should really look
Superman there was no shortage of angry
fans gripes about the DC extended
universe version of Superman but his
appearance probably isn't one of them
though it's not an exact replica of the
Comics characters usual threads comic
ovals physical appearance for the role
isn't one of the DC extended universe as
problems unless that is you really like
red Underpants one of the most prominent
distinctions of the new kal-el costume
is the fact that like everything else
about the modern take it's much darker
whereas the Superman of old done the
bright blue types of bright red accents
on a cape the new suit is somewhere in
the deep denim family with a scaly
texture woven throughout Superman's
super suit appears much rougher than the
leotards of Krypton's past and of course
it's hard not to miss a photic ovals
costume also ditches a thick belt and
outer britches featured in the drawings
it makes sense to Superman's original
alte Underpants design was based on that
of circus strongman of the late 19th and
early 20th centuries that's not really a
thing anymore so it's probably okay to
drop the underoos they finally have in
the comics to Batman in 2016 super punch
fest dawn of Justice Ben Affleck's
Batman was most obviously inspired by
the Caped Crusader's journey in the 1986
comic miniseries The Dark Knight Returns
in the forepart frank miller epic and
older Bruce returns from retirement to
combat rampant violence that has taken
over Gotham City and Jukes it up with
Superman along the way his costume too
is clearly inspired by the series the
slate gray color shorter ears on the
cowl and the size and shape of the bat
emblem is pretty much a direct mirror of
Miller's vision and the surest giveaway
for the bat flex true inspiration well
that on the fact that he basically said
it in an interview Zak was heavily
influenced by that I think everyone's
heavily influenced but that's the
seminal work right so I don't think
there's any of these that have been made
that haven't drawn from that book
because it's so good Wonder Woman
Linda Carter's version of Wonder Woman
from the 70s TV show established a very
literal rendition of the iconic DC
character but when gal gadot
reintroduced Wonder Woman in Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice she did it in
an updated alpha instead of the red
yellow and blue primary color scheme she
typically wears in the comics she dons
metallic body armor that fits in lightly
beside the new grittier versions of
Batman and Superman based on mass and
what she's won footage from 2017 s
Wonder Woman feature it seems that the
amazing Amazon's classic outfit has been
translated nearly perfectly to the big
screen Aquaman while other superheroes
have a long history of on-screen
adaptations Aquaman has only appeared on
television a handful of times and all of
them favored his usual orange and green
style instead actor Jason Momoa seems to
borrow more from Aquaman's later more
grizzled leur wearing a costume that
highlights his incredible brawn it's
basically Poseidon meets Khal Drogo and
that's awesome still this version of
Aquaman will always be closest to our
hearts oh hello wall chum green arrow
Green Arrow's costume on television has
gone through some tweaks but none have
quite lined up with the Emerald arches
longtime look from the comics while the
original is a not-so-subtle tribute to
Robin Hood Stephen Amell looks far
darker and more leathery in the new suit
additionally for arrows first season all
he didn't even bother wearing anything
to cover his face opting instead for
black greasepaint eventually he wised up
and went with a mask while keeping the
practical and modernized hood to go with
the show's urban setting the flash what
happens when you have a TV show about a
superhero but you want to include the
same character in your movies without
impacting either one you end up with
Grant Gustin and Ezra Miller both
playing a dude named Barry Allen the
flash the fastest man alive well the
fastest fictional man alive at least the
costume from The CW's TV series is
mostly faithful to the comic-book
original but it's a deeper shade of red
and has some unique style choices
there's a lightning bolt seams and the
headpiece that reflects his new 52
comics counterparts the fact that his
booths are red instead of the signature
yellow and the Lightning trimmings from
his waist and forearms have been reduced
and removed respectively I'm
the who now Ezra Miller's movie flash is
even more distinct looking almost like
he's wearing Armour inspiration for
Bella's movie flash it seems as the
characters look in the injustice video
game series in fact Agustin has declared
himself a fan of the new flash aesthetic
calling it sick and adding that he's
glad it's really different and takes a
different approach than the TV shows
street vintage feel hopefully one day
they'll actually me and we'll get a true
flash of two worlds style crossover
nerds can dream Connie Kid Flash kid
Flash's costume got a few alterations
and the flash TV series - the costume
worn by TVs Wally West has a mustardy
hue rather than a primary yellow and
Sonnen gloves as opposed to the separate
pieces in the comics meanwhile his belt
is thicker and distinct with a deeper
shade of red of course one of the most
significant and interesting changes is
that this version of Kid Flash is
african-american a new spin on a
character who for years and the comics
was white because comics are endlessly
confusing there is a comic book version
of Kid Flash reflexes new interpretation
but no matter who you think of as Wally
West that's still a pretty darn accurate
costume the atom while there are some
nods to the old comics renditions of the
atom the characters on screen
adaptations seems to have included a
full of molecular transformation from
his original appearance brandon rouse
outfit incorporates pieces of adam's
upgrade from DC comics new 52 reboot
like his XO suit an armored helmet in
place of his mask andy poon the concept
artist who created the new costume wrote
that the decision to replace a
character's signature spandex suit was
for practical reasons but he still tried
to emulate the feel of the traditional
blue and red pattern as much as possible
while keeping it more on the ground at
sci fi armor martian manhunter the
Manhunter from Mars ultimately known as
Jon Jones has been through a lot of
changes over as many eras of fictional
existence and his live-action adaptation
in TV Supergirl as to the characters
evolutionary history on the show David
Hare was makeup enhanced look for
Martian Manhunter draws from bits and
pieces of his comic past the shape of
his head bare as the new 52 style where
his cross shaped red chest design seems
like more of a nod to the style he's
rocked for years meanwhile the shape of
his eyes and the spherical orbs
costumer callbacks to the Martians 2006
standalone miniseries while the costume
itself seems like a militarized version
of what the character was drawn with in
the cartoon Justice League Doom even so
the Martians TV version stands on its
own
Supergirl if you're a superhero chances
are good you've gone through a few
significant costume changes here and
there and that's more true for Supergirl
than most so when Warner Brothers
decided to bring the girl of Steel to
the small screen they have plenty of
outfits to choose from which show
runners poked fun out during the show's
pilot episode I'm not flying around
saving people in this thing I I wouldn't
wear to the beach where's my cape capes
are lame
fortunately good sense prevailed and
Melissa Benoist Supergirl wears what's
probably the character's best version of
the outfit even with the textured fabric
that's become a staple of live-action
super heroics the Supergirl costume has
all the most important elements from the
bold blue top to the bright red boots
skirt and cape it's indisputable super
girls definitely the best dressed hero
on television nice to meet you by the
way nice to meet you too really like
your outfit I like your glasses
Thanks wish we could say the same for
the Red Tornado
yikes thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which live-action
DC heroes you think live the best
[Music]